all across ukraine ordinary people have
signed up to help the war effort many of
them are far from home after fleeing the
russian invasion to cities further west
for lots of women that meant leaving
their loved ones behind a fight
dw's funny fachar met a group of women
in the city of chennitzi in between
nights in a bomb shelter they're
spending their days volunteering to
support soldiers on the front lines
one doe at a time these women here had
very normal lives before the russian
invasion some of them teachers i.t
specialists their weapon for peace bread
yes
i know what it's like to be hungry it's
very important to feed others even those
you do not know we're all ukrainians
the bread shall feed soldiers men and
women at the front line marta lefchenko
spearheads the team of 30 volunteers
means coziness home love something we
can share
120 people share this house already it
was built for 80 by martha and various
donors five years ago to help survivors
of domestic violence
she now accommodates internally
displaced women and children
marina just arrived with her children
from keith after four days on the road
who scared a lot kids were either in the
basement or in a garage tears all the
time our country has been killed and
destroyed
she must eat though she's not hungry
concerned about her sister who is
stealing keith
the shelter is located in chernivtsi in
western ukraine still relatively safe
but fearing the worst preparations are
in place
what used to be a gym has become a
makeshift bomb shelter during the night
moments of comfort much needed for
everyone
in another room volunteers suing
ukrainian flags in high demand now
patches for soldiers to stop the
bleeding times of war highlight the
importance of women marta says
it's a robust
semester you do this because you have to
do it women do the same as men our women
are at the front line our women fight
and also die our women drive trucks and
lot flower in them
leaving ukraine with her two children is
not an option she says she cannot leave
her husband or her country behind and
she will be needed here too once the war
is over domestic violence will be on the
rise she says just like in 2014 when
fighting began in eastern ukraine
people learn to kill to be aggressive
and very often when they return home
they don't receive rehabilitation from
the government
they let their anger out on their wives
and children
we cannot imagine what will happen after
this war
no one can but everyone hopes for peace
we've been looking there at how women
are helping the war effort in ukraine
women and children also make up the
majority of the two million who have
already fled the conflict we want to
take a closer look now at their plight
and we can speak to anita battia she's
the deputy executive director at un
women she's joining us to speak about
this topic thank you very much for being
with us here on dw how does the
situation of women in this war differ
from that of men
well first at a very basic level the men
are conscripted and are fighting but
women are the ones who are taking their
children their families and fleeing
so
in this conflict as in any other
conflict women and children end up
bearing the disproportionate burden of
the crisis
well they those who are fleeing in
particular are at risk of becoming
victims of violence and exploitation and
this conflict and many others as you
said
what measures need to be put in place to
ensure that they are protected
when humanitarian aid is given it must
be given with the gender lens because
it is very important that the particular
exigencies of situations that women find
themselves in are taken into account for
example it's really important
uh to ensure that we are thinking about
women's physical needs which is not
something that necessarily comes
immediately to the mind of an ordinary
humanitarian worker so you need to think
about
what needs women may have particularly
in their caregiving function that may
require different physical
infrastructure
different uh kinds of provisions
different hours of service all of those
need to be thought through through a
gender lens
if we look at the situation facing both
women who are
staying to help the effort and those who
are fleeing what worries you most
well of course
the thing that of course worries us the
most is the fact that there is no peace
yet that is the overwhelming worry at
this stage that the fighting continues
that there is conflict that there are
more deaths but
to your specific question on what
worries us is there is a huge internally
displaced population now
and we will have to make sure that they
can live in a way that is dignified
and humane in the midst of this crisis
and for those who are fleeing
yes countries are opening up and giving
them
temporary residency but how are they
going to create new lives for themselves
in these new environments
and as we've already discussed it's not
only in ukraine that women and girls are
finding themselves in situations of war
crisis conflict where are you
particularly concerned about their
conditions
i wish i could say there was one place
where i was less concerned than others
the fact is the disproportionate impact
of crises on women is seen in every
single crisis whether you're looking at
women in tigray women in afghanistan
women in haiti and it doesn't matter
what the nature of the disaster or the
crisis is whether the crisis comes out
of war conflict or a climate uh climate
uh
disaster the impact on women partly
because poverty is so deeply feminized
is always worse than it is on other
segments of the population
anita speaking to us the u.n women's
deputy executive director thank you so
much for sharing your insights with us
today
it was a pleasure thank you
you